and left-hander blake snell is going for
the san diego padres the former cy young
award winner having a kind of rough
season
two outs nobody on for the catcher james
mccann three for nine with a home run
against blake
it's also struck out four times against
snell three balls in no strikes we'll
see if mccann is swinging he is and he
grounds it right to machado manny's deep
at third plenty of time with mccann
running
perfect throw across the diamond and a
one two three first
for blake snell gets away with that
three ball count no problem
andre is coming up against old friend
joey lucasi
then it's going to be a former padre
facing his old team tonight joey lucasi
will start for the mats the left-hander
one and three an era of 6.56
so here's manny at a six-game hitting
streak come to an end last night over
three with a walk in a run but
he might have won the game for the
padres defensively
here's the three and two to manny joey
into his wind up and the pitch is hit in
the air to deep left field palar going
back
looking up gonna go up to the second
deck and left
manny with his seventh home run padres
take a one-nothing lead on joey lucasy
here in the first
swag change for everybody
he's looking for he's asking everybody
where's my swag chain
he's got he's got the chain and i love
the
the way that thing spins that's the best
part of the whole thing
here's fernando tatis jr who hit a
two-run homer over the center field
fence
last night here's the 3-2 on the way and
it's on the outside corner he got him
looking
good finish to the inning for le casey
but the home run by machado puts the
padre in the crutch
in there for a call strike three drury
knew it
good curve ball from snell in for a call
strike first strikeout for blake snell
and he's retired the first five minutes
that he has faced
here's the very pesky billy mckinney
guy two home runs here as a brewer back
in april had the triple yesterday that
was nearly
a game tying inside the park home run
two and two to mckinney with two outs
nobody on in the second pitch from snell
right down the middle 98 miles an hour
strike three called
a one two three second for blake snell
couple of strikeouts
and we'll go to the bottom half of
inning number two padres in front one
and nothing
joe lucasy back to the mound for the
bottom of the second gave up a home run
to manny machado in the first one
nothing san diego
eric hosmer leads off in the home second
lucasy for a change is ahead 0-2
and swung on and missed by hosmer good
morning good afternoon good night
williams wearing number 70 nearly took a
home run away from fernando tati's
junior last night had the ball go in and
out of his glove
had one earned run against the giants in
five innings back at the beginning of
may
and he had two runs in five innings
against the dodgers in april oh two
swinging a mass there you go
97 up in the zone try and hit it mason
williams could not
strike three and strikeout number three
eight straight retired by blake snell to
start the night
here's luke casey does not have a hit
this year oh two to luke casey swung on
and missed strike three
nine up nine down for blake snell and
four strikeouts to start his night
blake snell has one hit in his career
it's come this season
one two swinging a miss he gets snell
with a fastball at 93. and one thing
i've noticed one time through the lineup
lucasie's fastball
varying speeds he's been anywhere from
91 to 94
so maybe that was a point of emphasis
change that up
and establish that as well now pillar
for one pitch is hit hard right at
fernando ends up on the seat of his
pants but he makes the catch
the line drive knocks him over and one
away here in the top of the fourth
and here's mccann who had a hard ground
ball to third his first time up
one and two to mccann the pitch from
snell is swung on and missed strength
three
got him with a curveball down in the
dirt and blake snell
has gone four straight innings to open
this game
12 up 12 down he's got 10 gloves
apparently that he uses and you're
correct ronnie he does not break them in
he just
he just uses them the way that he has
his gloves made he actually likes for
them to be very firm so that the ball
just kind of bounces out to him and he
can turn
double plays quickly the only thing
that's soft is that
um the the netting of it the the part of
the glove where when he's
going to his backhand he wants that ball
to really stick in there's the
former diamondback and yankee and blue
jay brandon drury
here's the o2 swing and a miss chased a
fastball away
strikeout number six for blake snell and
14 in a row sat down to start the game
14 up and 14 down for blake snell
mckinney took a call third strike his
first time up
billy making a seventh start for the
mets 26 year old from plano texas
former first round pick of the oakland
a's
seventh pitch of the at-bat coming to
mckinney
and he watches high ball four in the
midst of their first base runner of the
night
so after stellar retired the first 14 a
two odd walk to mckinney
in the fifth good at bat by billy
mckinney peraza over one he lined to
right field
down the left field line tommy fam
moving over and back to make the catch
so blake snell puts down the first 14
that he faces
he walks mckinney gets peraza the inning
is over
and we are midway at petco padres won
that's nothing
pham is over six against barnes meyers
at third revos at second with two out
one two coming
and the cutter head right back to barnes
he runs halfway flips at the rest
and that retires the side a king size
out for jacob barnes behind joey lucasi
to keep it a one-nothing game
mason williams stands in over one with a
strikeout waiting on the three and two
here it is from snell and a swing and a
miss struck him out with a 97 mile an
hour fastball
seven k's for blake and one out here in
the sixth inning
and now third time through as pilar gets
ready to bat
and on one and two a slider swung on and
missed it kicks away from the catcher no
problem
pilar is just going to walk back towards
the dugout he and snell exchange a
glance
and that is another one two three inning
for blake
snell he is through six without allowing
a hit eight strikeouts for blake
and after five and a half a one-nothing
padre lead
lendore hit one of the center field
fence that was caught by profar his last
time up
3-1 coming to lindor and he lines one to
left field
that's down for a base hit it gets by
fam and goes back to the wall
lindor on his way to second he's going
to take the turn and go for third
lindor slides head first he's safe
mets first hit of the game and fam let
it go by him to the fence
and just like that the tying run is on
third with nobody out
mccann tonight is struck out and
grounded out to third he ended both
innings
one two coming mccann swings and misses
strength three
tried to check on a high fast ball went
most of the way around
nine strikeouts for blake snell jury has
struck out twice
once looking in the second swinging in
the fifth hey
struck him out his tenth strike out of
the night
he works around the lead single and the
error and the only met hit of the night
leads to nothing the bases are loaded
for manny machado runners lead at all
three bases pitch coming he takes low
ball four
two nothing padres in the seventh now
cronin worth the batter with the bases
still loaded
2-2 coming to cronenworth
fly fall center field mason williams
right there
side retired but the bases loaded walk
brings in a run
two nothing san diego as they go to the
bullpen in the eighth
the batter will be the met who has
grounded into more double plays than any
other met this season catcher james
mccann
the lansing set of the belt kicks and
deals and this cutter is on the inside
corner
and strike three called mccann
immediately has some heated words and
has been ejected by the plate umpire
quinn walcott
he's going to get his money's worth now
he's been behind
go ahead he's been behind the plate all
game long
he knows better than anybody
and now rojas the manager has been
ejected and he'll get his money's worth
and now two on and two out for drury he
stuck him out in the padres win
melanson strikes out the side and the
padres shut up the mets two to nothing